so this is touristy stuff apart - this
is Wednesday morning and there's not
much going on we continue that at the
quest to find the Teddy and then we're
also go hopefully going to buy postcards
this is sounds very simple but I reckon
this is probably gonna take a while and
then this afternoon we've got the
stratosphere chopstick coupling so
pretty nice really beautiful the city
even if we don't know where we are
so it is the morning of Wednesday and
there's not much on today so I'm
actually sat in this disused room not
being used at the moment anyway just
gonna do some bike coding being here is
made me start thinking more seriously
about my client model and it's a project
which I sort of left for a while and now
I'm back on it and fixing mistakes which
I've made and it's the whole conference
is actually very inspirational I mean I
know that when I go back I'm gonna have
a lot more energy to do my research and
I think just being around people who are
showcasing what they've done suppose you
want it shows this is possible and you
know you get the opportunity to present
in front of all this people that's the
whole thing it's one of what I said in
one of my previous videos about viewing
something like this is an opportunity to
succeed rather than being a judgment on
yourself so I'm trying to make the most
of it all so I wanted to talk to you
about where I got this problem so
product placement it's a it's a Cola
beverage diet basically there is a young
scientist lab so um I think the
organizers realized that conferences can
be quite expensive for young scientist
like myself or with flights the
registration process and all that so
they've put on a young scientists lounge
where we can go and sit and work
everyone - and they put on free coffee
and cocoa now I said it and the biscuits
that kind of thing so I'm not saying
they're at MoMA because it's a bit
thought but also I couldn't film in that
people would look at me a bit weirdly
but it's awesome that we have that sort
of opportunity and it's a great
opportunity to mingle and make new
friends basically because half of the
point of this conference isn't
networking and that's something which
I'm really hoping I'm going to do this
afternoon at the stratosphere
troposphere event so I think you're
probably next see me
so I'm at the rocks of the earth exhibit
right now and these are locations and
that behind me where people have
submitted rocks that are members of the
conference so we've got rocks from most
of the year but there are a few you can
see down there the Sun plant plant occur
there's all over Asia that side you've
got all over America and they're all in
this display cabinet in front of me and
Tom put his rock which is Devon
sandstone from the beaches sipping along
with quite a few other people McCain and
that that's been put in the display and
hopefully by the end of this it's of a
spectrum of all the Earth's rocky
history I guess
yes I don't even gift-wrapped this which
is like it is Brian I think I'm not your
judge so I've no idea what it is but
it's a really really nice exhibit it's
pretty cool
so this is evening of the Wednesday we
just had the mammoth set in the astatine
on stratosphere chopper to a coupling
which was really really interesting
there was a lot of discussion between
two years talks in particular about how
you classify certain events that happen
in the stratosphere and very vocal
parties on either side so we listen to
both talks there was discussion in the
talks and then after all the talks
happened there's also the poster session
at the talks themselves you make notes
as well yeah notepad I've been sort of
taking notes on the talks and sort of
highlighting the key areas and it's all
about knowing who to talk to if like
you're learning from talks but it's also
knowing who to associate with each day
at work so you know it's useful in terms
of sort of plotting who does what I
guess in the area but they were talks on
how to classify these events they were
talks on the key Bo which is actually I
did my first piece of research on which
is something that was in the equatorial
stratosphere there was which is one of
the ways that the stratosphere
influences tropospheric climate sort of
indirectly and then after that we have
this poster session so I talked about
posters already but this was the first
time that we've actually been into a
session properly
so there were only about 20 about 20 21
21 poster [ __ ] yeah there's some were
missing because they just went blunt
presented about 20 posters on strap drop
coupling but in this hall there must
have been about a thousand posters and
it's incredible like the diversity of
research that was going because directly
next to us there was aerosol stuff yeah
and then even you know further along
there was more meteorology it was it was
all in the area of the atmosphere and
oceans stuff but it was just it was such
a range so so many people we ended up
talking to a guy whose work what has the
knowledge
hopefully gonna use and then talking we
haven't a long chat with the postdoc
from Cambridge about her work in these
classification of events but it's it's
such a vast array of scientists all
talking about science in one place it's
it's a little bit overwhelming like now
there are some great people was like
crowd people so we eventually just went
to the side and sort did a little bit of
work on our own the other thing was I
finally got my beer
finally finally got it tom was happy
with just water so unfortunately I was
going to get your wand but they run out
by the end of the session what's
happening now there is to sort of
continue that socializing thing we're
about to go off to dinner with everyone
else from the stratosphere troposphere
group they announced that they were all
going off to dinner somewhere in the
city
so our next adventure is to try and find
it we think you know we're going I think
we probably went during the filming
later tonight but we will see you
tomorrow for more stratosphere
troposphere coupling and possibly some
Mars science
this is lunchtime Thursday the landing
was there was for that sound
cervical next to was giving the talking
and so at her research so we were there
to support her first thing in the
morning absolutely set all those farik
sessions we've been to have been
absolutely rampant and that's why we're
not gonna change the dress the
conference they tend to be quite small
rooms and it's quite a big field what's
gonna happen now is me and Tom and ever
he arrives we're gonna go and get food
then this afternoon we have the
continuation of that session except
Tom's going to go to a keynote lecture
on the atmosphere which is generic and
then after that we're going to the great
debate so there's a you know across the
entire conference today on whether we
should Geoengineer the placard so that's
whether we should fix the climate
reverse climate change for example by
Concorde the planet it's a very very big
question and it's a very very serious
question and there's an interesting
contrast between young people that you
are making the decisions and they are
going to live long enough to actually
see them and it's being enacted so we're
gonna hope to get about so interesting
statistics by the way I found out that
there were 12,000 people at this
conference there probably more doctors
in this in this building than the Rhine
any hospital amazing
I hope I get to meet these guys on
okay so this is the evening of the
Thursday it's been quite a long hot
afternoon because the last tortilla was
at lunchtime and so since then we had
the afternoon session on the chemistry
of the upper it was history and then
after that we went to the great debate
which was packed come with predictively
and this was on geoengineering and they
had five five people who were actively
speaking and then they were going around
the audience taking questions my opinion
on geoengineering is that it should
definitely be researched but it not
implemented yet because we don't know
enough it's basically a last resort we
do you have yeah I mean the really the
question of the the debate was sort of
firstly is it right to do it is it is it
right to research it and then if we were
to do it what would we do and it was
quite wide-ranging actually there was
one guy who was talking he was actually
an engineer who had a very positive
outlook of global warming and it was
very pragmatic with a lot of anger he
wasn't he was pushing forward he was he
was enormous irritatingly optimist at
the point but no he was actually pushing
for experiments and doing the size I
think I aligned with him and the guy in
the middle
I think are some less intelligent
questions or they came up with very
negative because I mean this guy
basically asked at the end whether it
was he it was morally questionable to
research geoengineering which I strongly
disagree with I think it's it's
definitely worth researching I thought
what was interesting was the fact that
there was a there was a big split in the
middle basically between questions which
were asked about geoengineering from a
human perspective and those asked from a
physical perspective like you know in
terms of the feedbacks whereas a
physical question but then the human
impacts and possibility of you know how
many lives have we lost before we do it
it was a very much even question what
was a very interesting as well just
remember though the guy in front who he
asked he basically went on a rant about
overpopulation and saying this isn't the
solution to curbing overpopulation is
and he got the biggest round of applause
of the whole lot which I think I don't
know I felt very uncomfortable about
that well I mean like from a very cold
standpoint it's true population but it
indicates a very much kind of scientists
above all else kind of mentality
anything you like we basically him
saying there are their ups and then
there's the other people that over we
were breeding and all that kind of stuff
so that was yeah kind of questionable
would be how I described it but it
wasn't it was an interesting debate it
was it was good that there were it was a
public play as they said it wasn't
something which was behind closed doors
and anybody who was at the conference
could go seemingly most people have a
conference didn't go but yeah very much
worth having so it's a very important
subject and then after that we went off
to a workshop which was an our original
plan we were gonna go and we're gonna go
for posters yeah it was there was some
space space places and there were some
other stuff on the chemistry staff which
we saw earlier because it wasn't one of
them posters might get me rid of them so
we went up to this workshop on
scientific communication in traditional
media types so newspaper TV internet
internet websites for newspapers and
basically how to make sure your research
is correctly reported and isn't reported
erroneously
or misrepresented misrepresented or in
any other way distorted and it focused
on the role of the media the role of the
scientist in relation to the media and
also how to write a press release yeah
we had to do this exercise where we
basically paired up and then had to
write a press release for ourselves and
then give it to someone else and then
they would give like introduce our
research for us but given the atomic the
same thing pointless but that was
interesting I think it's really good
that they were offering that it's very
very important subject especially in
climate sciences and it was you know it
was very materials they gave us so
definitely get are getting refer to you
been doing it so anybody who need you is
watching thank you for doing that and
the filmmaking workshop we both yeah we
both found that very useful on the cards
for tomorrow is Tom just read out a very
long list of all the things that you're
on and none of them are relevant either
we're basically staying for the whole
week because we wanted to take up the
whole conference and so take you all in
my plan is to go and sit down and do it
today program yeah and do other things
like emails that I can do
so as it turns out I didn't actually end
up taking any footage on Friday because
I didn't really do anything the one
thing which mean Tom and I did do is we
went to a really interesting place of
the earth talk the last one on the space
in the earth which was about comparative
planetology and that's basically where
the earth has gaps in its geological
history because for example oceanic
crust it's continually cycle that's
destroyed when it gets subducted down to
continental crust and reborn when it
when it comes up for example you know in
the mid-atlantic ridge so there's only
so far we can look back on the Earth's
history and the point of the talk was
that you can look at other planets like
Mars like Venus to fill in a box in the
Earth's development that we just don't
have evidence for it gives us clues
about how planets formed the guy who
gave the talk actually was incredibly
interesting his first job out of college
as a university was to work on the
Apollo program debriefing astronauts on
their moon walks imagine that your first
job he was incredibly cool and we also
answered a question that I had about
Martian exploration so I was really
impressed that she was probably the best
thought we went to all week and for the
rest of the day I programmed I worked on
my client model and then we packed up
and we went home so I'm afraid that's
all the scientific content there is and
I'd really like to apologize that this
part is so late up basically I've been
really busy recently
mostly with work stuff and so that's
kind of had to take priority and why
YouTube works I'm really sorry that this
is really quite significantly late but
I'd also like to take this opportunity
to thank the organizing committee of the
conference who I understand it have now
found these videos I'm terribly sorry
about everything I've already said I
would like to say however that you did a
fantastic job I fought the conference
which was my first major scientific
conference was a fantastic experience
for me as a young scientist no
conference can be perfect and I've
already said before that the atmospheric
science sessions were in rooms that were
probably too small but I accept that
there are limitations on space that
every group had to face other than that
though I really couldn't fault the way
that the conference was run I thought it
was incredibly slick incredibly
enjoyable as well as being very
informative and great for professional
networking and all the stuff the
conference's as opposed to be so thank
you very much being on the conference
and thank you everybody who's watched
these videos these vlogs have actually
been quite well received so am I
I can do these more in the future and
let me know in the comments what you'd
like to see in terms of vlogging content
from scientific events because I'm
making this up as I go quite frankly and
any pointers would be useful as any
feedback always is so thanks for
watching and hopefully I'll see you at
the next conference whenever that may be